[Música]
el presidente de chile gabriel boric
comparecerá ante el congreso nacional en
su primera rendición de cuentas dos
meses y medio después de asumir el poder
y cuando los temas relacionados con la
inseguridad y la economía han copado la
agenda en estas últimas semanas la
portavoz oficial de boris y camila
vallejo explicó que el mandatario hará
un repaso a sus dos primeros meses en el
cargo como presidente pero también va a
tratar de proyectar los desafíos que el
gobierno tiene por delante esto por
estos próximos cuatro años en las
últimas semanas su popularidad en las
encuestas ha caído principalmente por la
creciente violencia en el sur donde la
semana pasada al menos un hombre fue
asesinado en el marco de un conflicto
territorial entre el estado chileno y
los indígenas mapuches para ello
entonces para analizar este tema con el
presidente de chile quiero salvar a
christopher martínez ls phd en ciencia
política y profesor de la universidad
católica de temuco gracias christopher
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 muy buena mañana de
miércoles y les quiero empezar
preguntándoles qué podemos esperar
entonces
de cuentas de boliche en que se enfocará
el presidente buenos dias raul gracias
por la invitación pero los principales
desafíos tienen que ver con tratar de
recuperar la agenda política y la agenda
de discusión que el gobierno ha estado
dejando atrás precisamente en estos casi
80 o más de 80 días que lleva en el
poder y también proyectar algunos pruebe
planea a futuro que fueron parte de su
programa de gobierno que tiene que ver
con la reforma de pensiones con la
reforma tributaria que son
modificaciones estructurales lo que el
sistema en chile s por un lado ha sido
una de las peticiones que ha impulsado
uno de los socios de la coalición que es
el partido comunista y que en el fondo
está esperando que el presidente se
refiere a estos temas y luego otro que
tiene que ver más bien con la coyuntura
que tú también describía es en cómo es
el presidente espera a lidiar con temas
que han estado manejando bastante fuerte
en la política nacional y en la agenda
social de chile que es el aumento de la
delincuencia incluso el aumento de la
gravedad de los delitos y la agresividad
de los delitos sumado a un tema de
inflación que es potente no solamente en
chile sino que en todo el mundo pero que
en el caso de chile es primera vez que
en los últimos 30 años un lado de la
inflación supera los dos dígitos y es
obviamente algo preocupante y como
viento decía esto está hundido un poco
en la popularidad presidente y su
desaprobación aumentó de un 26 por
ciento aproximadamente en marzo hasta un
56% a finales del mes de mayo ni
siquiera tiene tres meses en el poder y
ya va a ser una rendición de cuentas
christopher para nuestro para nuestra
audiencia internacional quisiera
preguntarle si esto es algo normal
digamos que ya cuando un presidente de
chile tiene 2 meses y algo pues tiene
esta primera rendición de cuentas antes
del congreso o que realmente está
ocurriendo con boliche
sigue algo normal en uno de los
republicanos más antiguos del país parte
en 1828 ni siquiera estaba incluir las
constituciones de 1833 y se empezó a
utilizar la fecha del primero de junio
como un hito republicano en el cual el
presidente rinde cuenta de su gestión
que hace promesa de los que se vienen
este hito se ha mantenido en cierto
desde esa época por casi 200 años y es
lo que está haciendo el presidente en
chile y como bien tú decías quizás no
puede rendir cuentas porque lleva
claramente dos meses y medio en el poder
pero si en el fondo estamos todos
pendientes de que va a decir acerca de
lo que se nos viene ahora a christopher
también es tratemos un tema muy
importante en estas últimas semanas y
también que venía con su antecesor y
sebastián piñera lo que está ocurriendo
en el sur de chile este conflicto
mapuche además que viene de años atrás
es recordemos también que boris en ese
momento dijo que no quería después
decretar un estado de opción como lo
había hecho sebastián piñera al final
tuvo que recurrir a este estado
decepcionó por el tema de seguridad tan
álgido tan álgido y tan preocupante que
se vive en esa región que es realmente
lo que ocurre y por qué el presidente
boris que se ve obligado digamos a hacer
algo que no quería como decretar el
estado emergencia en esa región
bueno yo creo que va un poco en lo que
todo acaba de mencionar tiene que ver en
como el presidente que distanciarse de
lo que han sido las políticas más bien
de derecha respecto de cómo lidiar con
el tema del conflicto del estado con el
pueblo mapuche y que en el fondo ha
cobrado una nueva víctima la novena
víctima en los últimos años de un
trabajador segundo acá 'thriller' a su
nombre una persona de la zona y que en
el fondo ha adquirido distanciarse
precisamente de ese tipo de política
está además en una región de derecha que
históricamente ha votado por la derecha
en donde pinochet en 1988 él ganó
precisamente en la región y donde él el
oponente de boliche en la segunda vuelta
pues antonio kast también se impuso
cómodamente en esas elecciones entonces
era un costo puede ser electoral y
también para el núcleo duro de lo que es
la coalición del presidente bots de
recurrir a un estado de emergencia en
los cuales los militares cobran un rol
importante en la mantención de la
seguridad en este caso de caminos y
carreteras pero en el fondo esto se ha
visto también reforzado por otro que no
socio la coalición que el partido
socialista que estaban los gobiernos de
chile de 1990
y que en todo lo bueno de la
concertación de centroizquierda y de
nueva mayoría me refiero y que en el
fondo estaba creando un mayor sentido de
responsabilidad porque precisamente la
escalada de este tipo de conflictos se
les está yendo de las manos del gobierno
y no estaba teniendo la respuesta
necesaria que también qué balance
podemos dar en estos dos meses y medio
de gobierno del presidente boris
realmente como lo estábamos conversando
anteriormente el presidente chileno se
ha desmarcado un poco de estas políticas
tradicionales
yo creo que lo intento y de hecho el
primer el primer gesto que tuvo el
gobierno del presidente de porsche en su
segundo día hábil de funcionamiento
porque la segunda autoridad política de
chile la administra del interior es que
así es visitó la zona de temucuicui que
está en la región de la araucanía y que
de hecho no pudo culminar su visita
porque se quemó un vehículo cuando
llegando ahí fue recibida con balazos y
tuvieron en el fondo que salir
arrancando ese fue un hecho de extrema
gravedad y que marcó la pauta de lo que
iba a hacer el gobierno y de los temas
que iba a estar refiriendo en la semana
siguiente entonces en ese sentido el
gobierno no lograba marcar la agenda ha
estado siempre corriendo detrás de la
agenda política no puede dar cuentas de
mucho avance en estos dos meses porque
además es un gobierno que se ha
caracterizado por no haber tenido la
famosa luna de miel quiten los
presidentes y en el fondo ha tenido que
enfrentarse a la coyuntura y a la
contingencia de una manera mucho más
dramática y en ese sentido la rendición
de cuentas no va a ser tal sino que en
el fondo se está esperando a que se va a
referir el presidente con estos temas
estructurales de reforma
[Música]
de pensiones y reforma tributaria y
también el otro proceso paralelo que
está viviendo el país que es cambio
constitucional